[Musique]
José Legault Michel COG Jonathan Trudeau
bonsoir
bonsoir commençons tout de suite avec le
pont tunnel parce qu'on vient d'en
parler avec la mairesse j'ai une petite
question symptômes de table pour vous ce
soit est-ce que vous regardez ça depuis
une dizaine de jours là les échanges et
déclarations est-ce qu'il y a une
mairesse me dit que oui y a-t-il d'après
vous une bonne collaboration maximale
totale efficace entre Québec et la Ville
de Montréal pour essayer d'atténuer
l'impact sur les gens José
j'ai l'impression que oui entre Valérie
plainte et Geneviève Guilbaud la
nouvelle ministre des Transports le
problème c'est que peut-être ça arrive
un peu tard parce que c'est le 31
octobre et là tout à coup quand vous le
disiez tout à l'heure en entrevue avec
la mairesse on a l'impression que
il y a comme un réveil mais il est
il
ce qui est troublant aussi c'est quand
même tu entends de la ministre guilbo
demander aux gens de se préparer un plan
B il
est tard Michel C
très d'accord et j'osais que c'est tard
il y a des erreurs par exemple à rendre
un Président de Chambre de commerce
l'auto
dans les circonstances je pensais pas
tant que ça de ciseaux c'est une bonne
chose est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
travaille encore assez probablement pas
puis n'oublions pas aussi qu'un morceau
du puzzle qui devait être là qui était
le RAM puis qui a quelques jours de vie
avant le 31 octobre non savez-vous on
sera pas prêt alors que tous les
rabattages d'autobus devaient faire etc
seul là-dessus la Caisse de dépôt comme
montrer qu'elle était un bon joueur je
pensais à vous qu'un seul annoncé ça
Michel Jonathan
Michel est plus divorce bref Jonathan
je moi je trouve ça troublant depuis
quelques jours de voir à quel point le
niveau de préparation n'est pas
satisfaisant et je pense que la
responsabilité elle est partagée
ailleurs une preuve de ça c'est qu'à
partir du moment où la conseillère
responsable la mobilité durable de la
Ville de Montréal un peu pointé du doigt
le ministère des Transports a dit on
aurait mis avoir plus de prévisibilité
on avait remarqué que le gouvernement
s'est défendu mais pas trop la ville a
pas trop insisté comme si les deux
étaient conscients que chacun leur côté
aurait pu en faire davantage j'ai aucun
doute que ce serait à ce stati colorbe
il collabore bien ensemble ils ont pas
le choix mais lorsqu'on dit qu'on
demande aux citoyens de se trouver un
plan B le plan B du gouvernement et de
la Ville de Montréal il est où lui moi
je veux bien qu'on fasse une gestion
dynamique du dossier en me disant de
l'humeur un sous-ministre qui va être
attitré uniquement à apporter des
ajustements mais j'aurais aimé qu'on
nous dise que déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines on travaille on travaille sur
un plan A B C D E F parce que clairement
je pense qu'il y a encore des gens
sous-estime à quel point est-ce qu'on va
vivre à partir de lundi pour être
catastrophique a tellement d'égardes bon
on va oui très bien on va y revenir la
semaine prochaine oui j'osais là-dessus
rapidement très rapidement c'est qu'on
voit c'est le même réflexe aussi qu'on a
vu dans les derniers mois avec la covid
on demande aux gens de gérer leurs
propres risques
écoutez là un moment donné c'est pas
aussi citoyen non plus à pallier des
situations qui n'ont pas contrôler
eux-mêmes vous parlez des citoyens qui
écopent je vous passe à la deuxième
crise devant ce gouvernement qui qui
vient d'être formé c'est les urgences
oui c'est pas nouveau non c'est pas
nouveau devrait agir quand même on va
écouter monsieur Dubé monsieur le groupe
on vient tout de suite
notre principal problème dans nos
urgences au Québec c'est qu'il nous
manque de personnel mais ça je vous
apprends rien quand je vous dis ça
aujourd'hui
on va tout faire pour essayer avec les
ressources quand je dis les ressources
c'est le nombre de personnes qu'on a de
donner les meilleurs services possibles
mais en même temps je veux pas penser le
convoi avoir une baguette magique tout
réglé du jour au lendemain puis je
trouvais aux suggestions puis on va
discuter aussi avec les représentants
bon je vous remontrerai le tableau mon
nom le montera plusieurs reprises depuis
plusieurs jours c'est du 200% il y a des
parents pour réussir plutôt pour enfants
notamment ça ça c'est compliqué à cause
des virus respiratoires mais dans les
autres urgences aussi bon vous voyez le
tableau ça parle il parle de lui-même
Jonathan je commence avec vous bien sûr
qu'il y a pas de baguette magique puis
on en parle depuis toujours mais il y a
quand même une crise à jakari pour
Monsieur Dubé maintenant
il devra livrer les résultats en même
temps on peut pas on peut pas tomber
dans l'utopie le fallait pas s'attendre
à ce que trois semaines après avoir été
réélu ce gouvernement là effectivement
avec une baguette magique réussissent à
régler tous les travers du système de
santé il faut aussi garder en tête qu'on
a un système qui est encore fragilisé
après plus de deux années de pandémie
des gens qui sont complètement au bout
de leur élastique mais là il y a un plan
qui est en place un plan qui nous a été
présenté avant la campagne électorale
qui à mon sens a pas été suffisamment
débattu pendant la campagne électorale
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça je
comprends les résultats ne peuvent pas
être probable du jour au lendemain mais
moi j'aimerais qu'on nous explique
comment ce qui a été promis les
engagements de Christian Dubé comment ce
fameux plan là va se matérialiser et
comment on pourra au moins commencer
petit à petit avoir des effets
bénéfiques de ce qui sera mis en place
par la CAQ parce que c'est ce qui
décourage un peu les gens c'est cette
idée que peu importe ce qui est fait il
y a jamais de résultats tangibles bah
question du pays devrait faire la preuve
du bien-fondé du bienfait de ses
promesses il nous a dit tout à l'heure
il a dit à la presse il y a un comité
j'ai demandé à ma souligner de présider
un comité de crise avec deux trois
directeurs généraux puis de donc
j'attends leur suggestion Michel saugé
effectivement on a l'impression que
devant puis c'est la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre beaucoup il y a comme une
impuissance mais qui fait mal à beaucoup
de citoyens quand même
c'est sûr qu'il y a une impuissance
écoutez de dire on va faire un comité de
crise ça règle absolument rien le
problème on le sait c'est un problème de
personnel de gens qui sont surmenés qui
lâchent la profession qui lâche qui s'en
va un autre qui de son plus au travail
dans la fin c'est l'histoire et on peut
pas les on peut former des gens
rapidement c'est pas comme les préposés
à l'infirmière rapidement on peut pas
former des médecins rapidement alors il
y a vraiment une difficulté pour le
citoyen de dire surtout que le ministre
de la Santé est le même qu'avant on a
pris même qu'on a recommencé
lui il faut sentir dire ça il y a pas il
y a pas vu il y a 1000
électorale c'est ça qui va être
difficile à expliquer pour le
gouvernement là on sait quel est le
problème mais on n'a pas de solution
je vais poser la question aux
représentants
des médecins
urgentologues cette semaine en disant il
y aurait pas une corvée urgence choses à
faire des démesures exceptionnelles pour
jusqu'à Noël puis ça semble compliqué
José qu'en pensez-vous
il y a vraiment un problème très sérieux
et et ça fait quand même des semaines
que les urgences ça peut commencer hier
et en effet pendant ce temps-là la carte
était en campagne électorale et c'était
silence radio il y avait pourtant un
ministre qui était toujours ministre là
et et la pandémie a quand même le
dollars c'est un système de santé qui
est profondément dysfonctionnel depuis
bien avant la pandémie la pandémie ça a
été un révélateur pour ceux qui
doutaient encore des dysfonctions du
système
ça les a révélés mais là on a une
situation où oui les urgences déborde
ont débordé depuis 25 ans en fait depuis
le 1er défi de zéro pour le dire mais là
c'est plus que jamais plus que jamais et
en même temps on nous a levé toutes les
mesures sanitaires et le ministre
aujourd'hui nous parle évidemment de la
covid ou par des virus respiratoires de
l'influenza qui s'en vient l'hiver et
nous dit dans la même phrase on a enlevé
les mesures sanitaires et c'était ce
qu'il fallait faire alors oui remettre
le port du masque dans les lieux publics
clos ça réglerait pas tous les problèmes
mais ça pourrait commencer au moins à
ralentir la propagation de tous ces
virus respiratoires là incluant
évidemment tout d'abord la covid et mais
tous les États ont commis cette même
erreur là c'est à se demander si mais
KenZy leur a conseillé ça à tous les
gouvernements en même temps mais
honnêtement il me semble que le port du
masque dans les lieux publics cette fois
personne un virus peut tuer c'était bien
placé mécanisme
félicitations pour cette finale
très bien des images du Conseil des
ministres
d'ailleurs je reviens en arrière
monsieur Dubé on le connaît bien puis
beaucoup estiment que c'est un des
meilleurs ministres de la Santé qu'on a
eu depuis des années depuis des années
des années aujourd'hui il a beaucoup
parlé dans son point de presse on essaie
de résumer finalement ce qui le dit ça
m'a frappé Jonathan que pour quelqu'un
qui aime les les chiffres les cibles et
tout ça il savait pas trop comment
prendre ça lui-même
mais c'est que la réalité c'est que
c'est très difficile de de donner de
l'espoir je reviens à ça là il y a une
situation qui est qui était presque
inévitable c'est-à-dire que l'octobre le
mois d'octobre arrive on est à l'automne
il y a des nouveaux virus qui font le
réparition des virus bon saisonniers qui
qui reviennent il y a pas de personne
qui pouvait passer que d'un coup de
baguette on serait en mesure de de
régler tout ça mais ce que je trouve
paradoxal c'est que le citoyen lui qui
écoute ça se sent vraiment perdu là je
lisais ce matin les articles où on nous
disait par exemple mais on a ressenti
dans les 10 derniers jours je pense
c'est quoi près de 50% des visites qui
auraient été utile pour aller à
l'urgence bon bah ok mais vous voulez
que j'aille où j'ai pas de médecin de
famille vous vous garantir mes affamés
je n'en ai pas mais en même temps du
même souffle on dit aux gens oubliez pas
de venir à l'urgence si vous avez
quelque chose de grave j'ai l'impression
que les gens ne s'y retrouve tout
simplement très bien ok c'est parce que
les urgences sont toujours été le canari
dans la mine au Québec du système de
santé
les lits sont bloqués en haut on nous
dit plus d'accès pour les résidents en
tout cas bref je veux vous parler sur un
ton plus léger de d'abord je vais vous
montrer les images du Conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui le premier ils ont
fait entrer les caméras on a vu où les
gens étaient placés alors on va tout le
monde va étudier ça qui est en face qui
est à côté je fais du Gabin qui est bien
franchement en phase de Monsieur le gros
donc tout va bien et là on a posé la
question madame Guilbaud même Guilbaud
dimanche soir
je suis Drainville était et était
vigoureux puis après toute la place puis
vous avez roulé les yeux un peu il y a
une caricature aussi je pense qu'on a la
culture ce matin voilà ou Bernard
drinville fait beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit pour voir au loin monsieur fait du
Gabin puis madame Guilbaud il prend
toute la place voici la réaction amusée
de Madame Guilbaud
est-ce que vous avez roulé les yeux
je pense que c'est un allié pour le
troisième lien on a chacun notre style
dans la vie puis tu sais moi ma
personnalité était que je suis pas
vraiment d'ego pour ses affaires là je
suis pas quelqu'un susceptible au
contraire je suis quelqu'un qui est
facilement diverti par ça par les
situations qui peuvent être cocasses
alors elle a été diverti Michel c'est
Auger
présente en politique il y avait une
tribune il pouvait faire ce qu'il
voulait il va falloir donner qui qu'il
se calme un peu parce qu'effectivement
bon est-ce que le roulait des yeux ou
non je ne sais pas mais je pense que
beaucoup de ministres qui iraient rouler
des yeux c'est à sa place en voyant
l'espace qui prenait Jonathan un moment
donné si on veut jouer en équipe pour
jouer en équipe le Premier ministre
devra parfois on le sent
arbitrer certaines choses
quand on dit que l'émission s'appelle
tout le monde en parle je peux vous
garantir que dimanche soir tout le monde
en parlait effectivement de la présence
de Bernard drinville les élus avec qui
j'ai changé tout le monde dit au dessus
vu Bernard au-dessus Bernard je veux
bien croire que Madame madame Guilbault
est une bonne personne mais de dire
qu'elle a aucun écho ni égo c'est sûr
que c'était c'était évident que Bernard
Bernard drinville avait pris trop de
place dans cette question-là il aurait
pu cependant mieux le positionner à mon
disait il y a trois interlocuteurs au
gouvernement qui peuvent parler du
troisième lien il y a la ministre des
Transports il y a le ministre
responsable la capitale nationale et il
y a le ministre responsable de l'autre
région directement touché la chaudière à
Palace ministre dont est responsable
Bernard driville mais moi je pense qu'il
est il est intelligent il est capable
d'être stratégique également Bernard
drinville a sûrement saisi le message
pour qu'on veut qu'il se dénature mais
en même temps il vient d'arriver il y a
des ministres seniors qui sont en place
qui tiennent aussi un peu à leur carré
de ça leur chasse garder faudra voir
comment il va s'adapter avec le temps
aussi José
la première c'est que je suis content de
voir que madame guilbou est capable
d'être zen parce que elle était vraiment
zen sa réaction ce qui m'amène à mon
deuxième point et j'aurais vraiment
donné ça pour entendre notre ex collègue
martine Biron analyser cette situation
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'elle en
pense la troisième chose évidemment
c'est que pour Monsieur drinville non on
va pas le refaire mais
évitez le même spinning là
on a cette expression là lorsqu'il est
avec des ministres femmes aussi ce
serait bien d'éviter ça un petit il nous
reste un peu de temps pour souligner que
sans surprise la motion du Bloc pour se
détacher de la monarchie a été battue
mais je vais vous montrer je pense qu'on
a les images il y a light Band qui prend
de plus en plus de distance le libéral
qui a voté avec le bloc il y a
qui a voté d'une [ __ ] donc avec le bloc
il y a aussi Alain réel je crois que
voter avec le blog donc c'est
intéressant Michel C il a
c'est comme si il y a une petite des
petites mouches là qui sont ajoutées on
dit pas que ce débat va aller très très
loin mais quand même Michel
et de rien
qui sont plus élevés que ça de Canadiens
qui disent ça va faire la monarchie plus
besoin de ça et ça c'est au Canada
anglais aussi proche de son Québec donc
à un moment donné
on n'est plus de majorité de
britanniques ou de français dans ce
pays-là il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
venus d'ailleurs alors les gens qui ont
pas d'attachement avec la couronne et
surtout pas vers Charles ok oui Jonathan
un petit mot rapide bah ce qui manque
c'est le sondage qui démontre c'est où
dans l'ordre des priorités des gens moi
je veux bien que les gens se disent on
veut passer à autre chose mais c'est où
dans les priorités quand le bloc c'était
sa première journée de l'opposition
depuis l'ouverture de la session la
gaspille à faire ça je me dis que Coulon
il doit y avoir d'autres priorités pour
ces gens José 20 secondes
ça ne se fera pas
de prédiction très très prudente très
bien alors voilà on voulait noter
qu'avec quand même un libéral
2nd exactement alors voilà merci à vous
trois bonne soirée à très bientôt au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI